good morning believe nation today's
message is act on your passion over to
you Tim Grover when you want to excel at
something what must you have did I just
hear somebody say passion in the
audience you know what passion is
passion is an emotion it's an emotion
without an action passion will get you
nowhere inner drive will get you nowhere
unless you act on it
you have to act on your passion you have
to act on your inner drive don't let
those feelings stay inside of you you
got to know what to do with them you got
to know how to make them work in order
to get what you want don't keep it
inside so my take on this is we all have
passions we all have goals we all want a
better life for ourselves and and in
most of our cases we know what we want
but not all of us act on those passions
and that's the difference it's not
enough to write it down in a journal
it's not enough to tell your friends
it's not enough to tell your family it's
not enough to dream and tell yourself
dreaming isn't enough we've got to act
on your passion if you want to live a
happier life if you want to achieve your
goals if you want to make more money you
want to have a greater impact
so my question of the day today for you
is I want to know what the first step
was for you to act on your passion what
was the first little step that you took
to actually take action stop just being
a dreamer and actually be a doer leaving
the comments below I'm gonna join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching you continue to believe and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events Press